winter is coming batten down the hatches
storm born Game of Thrones season 7
episode 2 let's see if I can even keep
track of everything that went on in this
let's start at the beginning and before
I get into spoilers because I'm going to
get into them quickly good stuff better
than the previous episode to reiterate I
did not just like the previous episode
but it was dull and just seemed to be
about establishing where everybody is
now this one not a ton happen until kind
of towards the end but it was more
active because instead of just character
standing around reminding us all who
they are what they want and what's in
their way we see them start to scheme
and make plans and that is way more
interesting so we get a lovely bit of
scheming and so back more than we get to
feel the dynamic of Daenerys and her
sort of cadre of support that she's
built up I love that she calls out Varys
for his shifting loyalties I love that
he comes right back at her with his
reasoning for it and love that entire
exchange I liked Tyrians plan it made a
lot of sense I in bed I loved that would
one lie Elena Terrell undermines all of
it just by saying I've known a lot of
cover men and I outlived them because I
didn't listen to them I love her so much
she's so awesome
I like that John seems to be playing it
smart and he's not doing what Rob did
which is being Noble but stupid
so John seems to be making the best
choice he can under the circumstances
with the information he has I am
slightly nervous about the fact that he
left Sansa in charge because what I do
not want that happen but I will not be
surprised if it does is that for
whatever reason Sansa can't run stuffy
the people aren't listening to her she
gets overwhelmed who knows what and then
she goes running to Littlefinger for
help and then we're all screwed I am
really really hoping that is not where
they go with her but we had a nice
little reminder from Theon that
sometimes people don't overcome their
damage and that was a really sad moment
I at this point I do genuinely feel bad
as for Theon because
for what he's been through and what he
was facing at that moment I can't say I
blame him jumping off that boat you're
on is turn out to be a bigger player in
all of this than I have figured I think
he's good he might end up being a bit of
a wild card he's doing way more damage
than I thought he was going to do so
that that can throw a wrench into things
I mean that and that's one of the things
that's cool about this episode we see
people laid plans and then we see them
completely fall apart because of this
one guy that they hadn't counted on
I like how seriously sort of frames the
the issue of Daenerys coming back she's
really good at spitting in making
Daenerys look like the bad guy and all
this that works really well I'm kind of
torn on sir Jorah coming back and that
whole thing I'm going to wait and see
how it pays off right now I'm iffy on it
and here's the reason why I really liked
the idea that how we saw him exit when
he left the show previously was going to
be the last time we saw him because
there was something sweetly tragic about
that that he's basically going off to
die and there was nothing he was going
to be able to do about it but that
Daenerys by giving him that mission get
yourself cured gave him a purpose so in
my mind it was this wonderful poetic
thing that he was still going to die but
he was going to die with purpose trying
to serve the woman he loved so the fact
that he might actually survive
I don't know again I'll see how it pays
off I'll see if bringing him back mines
something that I liked more than when I
thought he wasn't coming back so we'll
see that was woo boy Sam props on you
Sam for you know stepping up to actually
do that job because also in Old Town we
got a little bit more Jim Broadbent I
think I actually forgot to talk about
Jim Broadbent last time and I'm always
glad to have him I've never not liked
Jim Broadbent up liked him and
everything I've seen even movies that
I've hated little Moulin Rouge crew but
he is always good he is wonderful at
being determing ly pompous which is a
weird thing to be able to pull off but
he can do it very well
the whole thing with great
Wurm and miss andy was fine i suppose it
was the obligatory nudity for the show
and not not exactly complaining about
that but at the same time I you know you
follow my channel you know that romantic
subplots are not exactly my favorite
thing in the world but it didn't drag it
down too much and it was something that
it's been built up to this point Aria
has some interesting moments hot pie
came back that actually made me really
really happy and I love that he's still
sweet and she just doesn't know how to
deal with the fact that he's sweet
that's just that's just nice and then
the whole Nymeria thing I really liked
too and I know that you know she has a
moment at the end where it makes you
wonder was that really was it not
regardless of whether was I think it was
it was a nice moment and I enjoyed that
I find it interesting that she is headed
back to Winterfell and I guess it was
also a reminder of it because it is one
of those things you forget because
everyone has to communicate through
Ravens and if nobody else knows where
you are you're not going to get the
information so I forget who dozen
doesn't know what and it hadn't occurred
to me that she didn't realize that the
Bolton's were out of Winterfell at this
point so the fact that she's now gotten
this information and she's turning
around and heading back to Winterfell
that's interesting because it seems like
she's I'm not going to say abandoning
her quest for vengeance but she's
shifting her priorities she has decided
it is more important to reunite with the
family that she still has been to seek
revenge and she's not as single-minded
as it was looking like she might end up
being and maybe that's even a way for
her to have Redemption I don't mean
Redemption like ah she she did horrible
things by killing Walder Frey Walder
Frey deserved to die but she's very
damaged and very dangerous at this point
so you know maybe maybe there's a shot
at at a happier ending for her because
I've already kind of predicted that
things cannot end well for her but we'll
see you as far as that goes that'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
given the track record
every time she tried to get to place the
where theoretically she'll be safe
it goes horribly wrong right before she
gets there maybe this is a bad omen yes
that's about it we had a bit of death of
a bit of very bloody violence then I
guess we lost some of the sand snakes
it's hard for me to care I don't I don't
don't care about Dorne I never I liked
Oberyn that's it everything else having
to do with door I just don't care but
we'll see where it goes so Steven page
that we'll see what it leads to maybe
again maybe like with surgery it'll
eventually land at a payoff that will
justify its inclusion or rien clusion or
whatever but that ain't there yet but
overall I liked this episode a lot and
even it didn't have to be chocolate
block full of action for death
breaks you just moved the story forward
a lot more than the last episode did and
this does that and that makes me very
happy so I am pumped I enjoyed this
episode I'm looking forward to the next
one have you seen Stormborn what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast I am also one
half of the punch like a girl podcast
both available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]